it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching at the only breakfast show
live from westminster sky news has
uncovered evidence
of the strict controls that uyghur
people are subject to
in china including half military style
management
and as the deadline approaches for civil
servants to declare any second jobs they
hold outside government
it's been revealed that the health
secretary matt hancock was given shares
in a firm that does business with the
nhs
also coming up this morning rhubarb
on the catwalk will be chatting to the
pensioner dubbed the vegetable king
who's been made one of the new faces of
the global fashion chain gucci
that's coming your way at quarter to
nine also ahead
you are a warrior
fight until your last breath
[Music]
and a quarter to ten we'll be talking to
the scottish singer songwriter callum
beatty dedicating his new song
to a teenager from his hometown he was
given an unexpected cancer
diagnosis it is friday the 16th of april
under control sky news uncovers evidence
that uyghur people from xinjiang
are being advertised online to work
under so-called half military management
deadline day as civil servants are
ordered to declare any outside jobs they
hold
the health secretary is facing questions
about shares he was
given in a company working for the nhs
[Music]
final preparations are being made for
the duke of edinburgh's funeral
as it's announced princess william and
harry will not be standing side by side
chicago shooting police release body cam
footage of an officer
shooting dead a 13 year old boy as he
appears to raise his hands
drawbridge daredevil police in florida
are searching for a motorist who jumped
their car
across an open bridge
and in the sport arsenal manchester
united both reached the europa league
semis
to remain on course for an all english
final
[Music]
and so far this week it has been fine
and settled but will it continue that
way into the weekend
i'll have the answer for you later in
the programme
morning all sky news has uncovered new
evidence
showing the strict controls that uyghur
workers are subjected to
in china including political
examinations
and half military style management
websites there are advertising workers
in batches of 50 to 100 some with
security guaranteed by the government
beijing well has faced growing
international pressure over the issues
but calls it the lie of the century our
asia correspondent tom cheshire
has our first report
these are uyga workers featured on
chinese state media
celebrating the islamic festival of eid
they are not in xinjiang their home but
thousands of miles away
in shandong east china rights groups
allege that sending uighurs to factories
around the country is indicative
of forced labor that they are subject to
strict controls as part of a policy of
assimilation
china rejects those claims but sky news
has uncovered evidence of the tight
social
and political controls applied to weak
requests for comment
we phoned some of the numbers listed
[Music]
ultimately the government decides where
workers go another agent told us
[Music]
the workers end up in factories like the
one in the video
we went to shandong to find out more
when we arrived at the seafood
processing factory
it was a very different scene there are
no uyghurs here
the factory owner told us they've all
returned home because of the pandemic
he described the idea of forced labor as
nonsense saying workers came here
because they chose to
earned at least 300 pounds per month and
had air conditioners in their on-site
dormitories
but they were under close supervision
the cctv cameras in the office monitor
those dormitories
riot control gear is also at hand and if
workers wish to leave the factory to go
shopping the owner told us
the company would drive them into buses
in the meantime he had called the police
12 officers and communist party
officials questioned us for two hours
before ordering us to leave town
our questions were not welcome at
another seafood factory in the same
province
for years it has run a uk subsidiary
registered in london
this manager was waiting at the door he
told us bluntly there were no
wiga workers here nor had there been in
the several years he had been employed
at the factory
that's contradicted by photos posted in
march last year on the company's website
which have since been deleted it shows
wiega workers arriving from xinjiang
the accompanying announcement says that
their arrival will help poverty
alleviation
and the integration of the national
family this is a coastal
export city some 2000 miles away from
landlocked xinjiang it comes with a very
different
way of life uiga workers are being sent
all across
china to different cities at the very
least it is a
vast labor transfer program and it's one
that requires a whole industry
around it the chinese government has
been mounting an aggressive publicity
campaign
in reaction to the allegations of forced
we were invited to this press conference
in beijing earlier this year
questions had to be pre-submitted in
order to attend
we were told this uyghur man had taken
part in the labour transfer program
if this labor isn't the worst if it
isn't forced why do they need government
supervision
[Music]
sky news asked the chinese government
for a response to our story
but after a week had received no reply
even here in east china so far away from
xinjiang
answers are hard to find
ah well let's bring in tom joining us
now back in beijing
tom good to see you this morning i mean
the reporting is quite incredible we
have had plenty of evidence of the way
in which the uighurs have been treated
but the level of control the degree of
complicity of the chinese authorities
and all of this is
is further revealed by your reporting
yeah i mean it's fair to say the chinese
government has been on a journey when it
comes to representing what's happening
in xinjiang when the first
reports of these mass internment camps
came out in 2017 so quite a long time
ago
for a long time china denied they even
existed then after more and more
evidence was uncovered
they said these were like boarding
schools vocational training centers
and then they said that everyone had
graduated from the camps and the focus
became what happened to uyghurs after
they left these camps whether it's in
xinjiang
or outside china as in that report and
allegations of
forced labor and china has changed this
year it's not just defensive it's really
gone
on the offensive with this uh lots of
documentaries being made by state media
attacks on those who say there is
forced labor it has got very very
aggressive in terms of denying
what others are saying is happening in
xinjiang and ultimately that means it's
doubling down
on its strategy xi jinping the chinese
president has said its policies in
chiang chang
are absolutely correct despite all the
international pressure there is
there doesn't seem to be any possibility
of a compromise so every new piece of
evidence that is uncovered
is certainly useful but in terms of
changing what's happening
uh is taking a very very long time
indeed for china to modify any of its
strategies in xinjiang
or in the rest of the country tom
many thanks uh former leader of the
conservatives ian duncan smith at
johnson's on the program of course ian
duncan smith yourself
sanctioned by the chinese last month for
comments you've made
about the uyghurs i'm just wondering
your response uh to that which we saw
from tom we have
plenty of evidence of course of the the
treatment that the uyghurs have had
but tom's reporting i suppose gives us
just a little bit more detail of the
level of interference political
interviews
military style management that these
people have to experience
yes i mean it's a a very good report he
should congratulated for
uh having put that together the truth is
that the chinese authorities
are engaged in in absolutely no question
in my mind now
genocide what they're trying to do is
they're trying to eradicate
an ethnic group uh which essentially is
sort of
somewhat turkic in origin and not set
the same as the han chinese
and they don't want them because they're
troublesome so what's actually going on
now
is a number of different prongs of
attack he's absolutely right there are
uh workers uh wego workers now all over
the country
thousands of miles away in forced labor
but the uyghur women particularly
they've been forced into
uh sterilization so you've seen in the
later figures the population drop
in the uyghur population it's a
deliberate and
uh systematic attempt to rid themselves
of what they consider to be a
troublesome
muslim group in one part of china
but this is not alone there as he would
certainly point out
this is going on in tibet there's over
half a million now
in forced labor camps they've cracked
down on
christians have their churches smashed
uh falun gong have been arrested
organ harvesting against their will and
i gather now there's a crackdown taking
place
on the inner mongolians over their
language this is a very specific
policy by the chinese government which
is to basically
make china based on one element of
ethnicity which is han chinese
and i think this is shocking the world
is beginning to complain about it
but i think the western world the free
world has got to do a lot more than that
you yourself have just identified this
as a as a genocide taking place the
governments we know of course of the
united states and canada
have have already done so there is a
vote in parliament next week i mean is
it your view that it is now time for the
foreign office to step up and
and label it such well the government
refuses to
say that this is genocide because they
say that only a court
uh competent court can do so but the
problem we've got is
the only competent courts that can call
a genocide a genocide
concerning a national purpose
are actually either the international
criminal court or
the international court of justice now
china's not
a signatory to the court of justice or
rather to the criminal court
and the court of justice gets blocked at
the u.n in the security
council which they are a member and
their allies that they pay the belton
road allies the developing world
all line up with china because they
receive huge sums of money
from china china is now very
aggressively pushing its own
concept of how to govern and how to run
areas like xinjiang around the world it
doesn't care what we think
it lashes out at people like myself who
say so and actually it's busy now trying
to redact all the information
that we've been using so the latest uh
documents i gather
about population uh don't have
population numbers a whole section has
been taken out of them
in xinjiang province so you can see
what's going on they're refusing
to accept but the west has been pretty
weak on all of this from start to finish
yeah just in terms of the levers that we
hold that might perhaps compel the
chinese to
to change their attitudes to change
their behavior i mean if they they don't
care what we think then
then many of the kind of the tools of
soft diplomacy don't really appear to be
at our disposal
well we need to be a lot tougher on the
trade issue the one thing china
absolutely needs is a very heavy amount
of trade
uh with the free world um mostly
investments really huge investments
uh from countries in the free world from
the west from america from britain
uh from places like germany they're very
vulnerable to that trade issue
and what we should be saying to them now
is we can't trade
really in the same way that we do with a
country that is such
an abuser of human rights we need now to
start
saying to the chinese you can't have
everything you want your cake and eat it
in this particular case until you stop
this
appalling behavior which is ruled out at
the at the u.n
but which you are pursuing then we now
need to think about what we do about our
trade and we're already far
too dependent on china for a whole range
of things the covet outbreak
showed just how ridiculously dependent
we are on china we've got to start
bringing some of that manufacture
and some of those elements of trade back
uh to win with countries that we
actually can rely on rather than
china china is deliberately and
determinedly
absolutely certain that they can get
away with this because they know that
the free world
may bluster a bit about it but won't do
anything about it it's time for action
um
we are just about to run out of time
serene but i do want to kind of uh
finish our discussion on a slightly
different topic a number of stories that
have been around over the past few weeks
about
corruption in politics about lobbying
from from from
former politicians i don't need you to
speak specifically to any of the stories
that are around but
but much as with the situation with
china and the uyghurs
there doesn't appear to be an easy
solution to all of this i mean
is there a way that we can have people
who worked in politics either in the
civil service or in ministerial office
working in the private sector after that
public sector employment would
without any questions ever being asked
about it
well to pick this point up
the truth is this is about people who
leave uh government whether it be civil
servants or politicians
and uh go out to do other jobs
that's quite clear you can't stop people
leaving government to go and do other
jobs
you couldn't stop somebody leaving one
company and moving to another
there's always issues about the overlap
in that they are meant to delay their
arrival at another company and that i
think needs to be
better enforced there needs to be a time
break but also
you know it's quite for those who are in
parliament those are
in house commons there are very strict
rules there are very strict reporting
uh regulations and requirements for
those that leave
there needs to be a tighter concept of
how they
work with governments that they may have
left or other governments so
everything has to be absolutely above
board there's nothing wrong
in trying to promote i don't think some
industry that may well benefit
the uk but it has to be done in a very
open way
uh that uh that means that this is done
officially in decisions
uh are taken uh in a proper process so
they can't they can't be seen to have
been influenced
by a a relationship with someone
all they can be seen to do is be
influenced by the nature of the
of the details and documentary evidence
so so this has got to be tightened up
for people on departure whether they be
civil servants and there's absolutely no
way
that someone should be working both in a
department as a civil servant
and in a company outside they can be
seconded to companies
they shouldn't be working in both you
can't have a foot in both camps
ian duncan smith good to see you this
morning thanks very much for being with
us
still to come on the programme uh around
about half past seven we'll be speaking
to the other side of the chamber
labour's jonathan reynolds
at the party saying that the
government's kickstart job scheme
is being ruled out too slowly
as the final preparations take place for
prince philip's funeral in windsor we'll
be speaking to the royal commentator
jenny bond
that's at quarter to eight
[Music]
and at half past eight owen patterson
will be on the program to tell us about
his new suicide prevention charity
in memory of his wife rose who took her
life last year
oh well let's return to that which we
were just discussing in fact with ian
duncan smith a moment ago today the
deadline for civil servants to declare
any
second jobs that they hold outside the
government and as that that's been going
on it's been revealed at the celtic
we'll be with you in a minute rob you
just stayed there the health secretary
was given shares in a firm
doing business with the nhs set rob
powell of course in the studio with us
let's
let's start shall we um green cell how
many inquiries are there currently on
going into exactly what happened
i think we're up to about seven now
various lawyer-led inquiries of course
committees of mps
uh conducting inquiries as well and i
think they've got plenty of material to
get their teeth into this morning
revelations in the guardian about
another individual with connections to
the civil service
and the cabinet office who was also
working at greensell this is david
brierwood who on his linkedin profile
between 2014 and 2018 was a crown
representative in the cabinet office
basically a part-time executive
responsible for getting value for money
for the taxpayer
also on that profile though between 2014
and 2021
he was a director at green sill capital
now the cabinet office say that he had
nothing to do with procurement he had
nothing to do with supply chain finance
which green sill did
so basically saying everything was done
um appropriately but i think this does
show
just another link between this company
uh and
individuals working at the centre of
government and we keep hearing from from
the other side of the chamber from the
government of course but from from all
the parties on it you know accusations
of cronyism those unlikely to go away
today
another story this time involving the
the health secretary yeah matt hancock
this is reported by the health service
journal in the guido fawkes blog
essentially
matt hancock's sister is a director of a
company called topwood limited which
provides
waste management solutions um storage
shredding things like that now matt
hancock also has a 15
um of shares in this company which he
was gifted earlier
this year now this company is an
approved supplier for nhs trusts
in england doesn't necessarily mean it
does work but it's basically
on a list that means it can be used by
nhs trust it's secure enough to do
public sector work
like that it also has done a lot of
business with the nhs in wales which of
course isn't matt hancock's
responsibility
now these shares have been declared in
the mp register of interest
i think the slight issue might be that
in the ministerial register of interests
the connection through his sister to
this company
hasn't been declared now that's what
labour is zeroing in on today and
accusing him of cronyism for his part
the department of health and social care
says that matt hancock cleared this with
the permanent secretary
they didn't think there was any conflict
of interest they say that he's not
responsible for awarding
um any of these contracts but i think in
the current climate
it's no surprise that people think that
the rules in this area perhaps need
looking at again
rob thanks very much indeed now
it will be a service infused with all
the traditions of the monarchy
but one that will also observe
coronavare's restrictions
buckingham palace has released details
of prince philip's
ceremonial funeral tomorrow which will
of course be attended by only
30 of his closest relatives instead of
the 800 guests
originally planned to attend our royal
correspondent rihanna mills
has the detail
arriving to support his mother the
prince of wales was driven
into the grounds at windsor castle as
the military carried out their final
preparations
ahead of his father's funeral tomorrow
the irony of covid is that the duke of
edinburgh
who never liked all the panoply and
state wanted
no dramas about his dying and this
is the event that perhaps he would have
most required
it is measured it is tidy it is
disciplined
and it's the best salute the armed
forces could give
30 people will make up the congregation
with the duke's children and
grandchildren
represented in the procession to the
chapel led by the prince of wales
and princess anne the queen will be
accompanied by a lady in waiting as she
is driven behind the coffin
family members will be socially
distanced will wear face masks and the
congregation
won't sing with a seating plan not due
to be released until saturday
it is anticipated the queen may sit
alone
and members of the family will not wear
military uniform
and that's to try and keep the attention
away from those who've recently stepped
away from royal duties
and keep the focus onto the legacy of
prince philip
inevitably though there is going to be
interest in prince william and prince
harry brought together
again to mourn their grandfather's loss
walking in the same line in the
procession behind his coffin
but separated by their cousin peter
phillips
it's hoped that touches like this will
be a reminder of the man
they'll be remembering this unique mode
of transport chosen by the duke
to carry his coffin a land rover that he
helped design
mike gretton worked alongside prince
philip as the chief executive
of the duke of edinburgh award and saw
for himself
the family man that he could be we were
in buckingham palace
and the the magic hour arrived for the
meeting to start
and he wanted to get on with it but
one member wasn't there and that was his
son prince edward
he was quite grumpy so well let's get on
with this but two minutes later
the door opened and in walked prince
edward
and the first thing you've heard me did
was leak to his feet and kiss him on
both cheeks
now i was caught out by that it was
lovely to see
and not what i expected it just shows
his love for his family and his humanity
on saturday it will become clear just
how much prince philip
was involved in the planning from the
music to military ceremony
making his mark until the very end
rhiannon mills sky news at windsor
castle
and just a reminder that full coverage
of prince philip's funeral will be
taking place here on sky news we'll have
a special programme
uh starting tomorrow at half past 12 and
then there will be additional
live coverage on sky one from 20 to
three
police in chicago have released video
from the body cam of an officer
who shot and killed a 13 year old boy
adam toledo raises his hands and is then
shot the officers
then administer first aid an independent
board is now investigating the shooting
immediately after the incident the
police claimed adam had a gun
in his hand but his family's lawyer says
the body cam footage
disproves that allegation to the trial
of the man accused of the murder of
george floyd
in minneapolis so it began nearly three
weeks ago
derek chauvin has now addressed the
court for the first time
but only to invoke the fifth amendment
the right not to answer questions and
incriminate himself his legal team have
now rested their case as the trial nears
its end in a city
still tense after that other fatal
shooting sky
sally lockwood reports now from
minneapolis
after nearly three weeks of evidence
we've heard in court for the first time
from former officer derek chauvin
is this your decision not to testify it
does your honor
all right do you have any questions
about your right to remain silent or to
testify
on your own behalf not at this time i
don't right does anyone
uh promise anything or threatened you in
any way to keep you from testifying
no promises or threats your honor do you
feel that your decision not to testify
is a voluntary one on your behalf
yes it is as expected derek shoving
chose not to testify in his trial
for the murder and manslaughter of
george floyd
the defense has now rested its case
arguing george floyd died of several
factors
including drugs and a heart condition
with a final rebuttal the prosecution
recalled a witness
to speak to derek chauvin's knee on
george floyd's neck
what they argue was the cause of death
as soon as you put pressure here you can
immediately sense
that your upper airway is narrowing
the trial is now playing out in the
backdrop of protests
sparked by the death of another black
man by police
twenty-year-old dante wright killed in a
routine traffic stop
by officer kim potter who claims she
fired her handgun instead of her taser
by accident george floyd's family lawyer
is now representing the wright family
too unbelievable that
the police woman killed
a another unarmed black man
while the derrick chauvin trial
regarding the killing of george floyd is
going on
cannot believe it if ever there was a
time in america
where they should be de-escalating it's
now
the outrage over these two deaths by
police have converged in minneapolis
the courthouse and much of the city now
locked down
and boarded up there was already a heavy
security presence here
for the trial but that has visibly
stepped up
since the shooting of dante wright on
sunday and the nightly protests that
have followed since
there's a real concern here that things
could only escalate
by the time of verdict the outcome of
one of the most important
criminal trials in u.s history now
hinges on 12
jurors who we expect to begin
deliberations
next week sally lockwood sky news
minneapolis
also this morning police in florida are
trying to identify the driver of a
vehicle
caught on camera jumping over an open
drawbridge
the footage shows the car smashing
through a traffic barrier
before jumping the bridge over the
halifax river in daytona beach let's
just see that one more time so okay it's
not the biggest jump i've ever seen but
i would certainly not recommend it uh
time to see how the weather is looking
this morning nas is standing by at the
wall with all the details
at morning now you've never done
anything like that have you
no i couldn't believe that literally my
jaws dropped open i mean that that's
wow um dedication to get to work i guess
i don't know anyway
uh it's looking fine out there for today
once again it will stay fine for the
rest of the week let's have a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning high pressure keeping
things fine and settled once again
across the vast majority of the uk and
ireland
for today and actually for the rest of
the week most places continue
dry with some good spells of sunshine
but nights are
chilly in fact generally speaking it's
quite cool for the time of year and so
far this april
temperatures have actually been a few
degrees below the average as a daytime
high so
this morning it's chilly frosty for most
places but it's mainly dry bit of mist
and fog across the eastern parts of
england that should soon disappear
then we continue with sunny spells into
this afternoon a little bit of fair
weather cloud bubbling up so the best of
the sunshine over northern and western
areas where it will feel
fairly warm with the light winds too
except across the far northwest of
ireland and northern ireland cloudier
breezier there with a little light rain
across north west scotland possible
later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thank you still to come on
breakfast we'll be speaking to the
shadow work and pension secretary
jonathan reynolds
as labour criticizes the government's
kickstart jobs program that's next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back sky news has uncovered new
evidence showing the strict controls
uyghur workers are subjected to in china
including the need for political
examinations and half military style
management the former conservative
leaders in ian duncan smith
believes that china's treatment of the
uyghurs amounts to genocide
earlier he told the program the uk needs
to take a tougher stand
on the alleged abuses by limiting trade
with china
well we need to be a lot tougher on the
trade issue the one thing china
absolutely needs is a very heavy amount
of trade
uh with the free world um mostly
investments very huge investments
from countries in the free world from
the west from america from britain
from places like germany they're very
vulnerable to that trade issue
and what we should be saying to them now
is we can't trade
really in the same way that we do with a
country that is such
an abuser of human rights
new research suggests that young people
who catch coronavirus
aren't fully protected against getting
the infection again
skies becky cottrell has been taking a
closer look at morning becky just tell
us
how concerned should people be about
this well the results from the study
are interesting because they suggest
that participants who
caught covert 19 were susceptible to
becoming
re-infected within a relatively short
period of time
the study looked at more than 3 000 u.s
marine recruits those are people about
to start their training
as a marine the participants were
predominantly men
aged between 18 and 20 years old and
they were tested across a six-week
period before their training began and
of the 189 participants that tested
positive for covert 19
earlier on in the study 19 of them
that's
10 percent caught covert 19 again
during those six weeks now while this is
a relatively small study the researchers
say the results are interesting because
they show that a small but significant
proportion of the participants
were susceptible to becoming infected
again
they also looked at antibody levels and
as you might expect those people that
were infected
again had lower antibody levels than
those that
weren't they also had fewer neutralizing
antibodies those are antibodies that
literally neutralize an infectious
particle
when it enters the body now obviously as
we open up and start mixing again there
are concerns about the effect that could
have
on infection numbers and government and
scientists
want to find out more about the
protection offered by antibodies both
from natural infection
and from the vaccines and how sort of
long-lasting and powerful those
antibodies might be and this study was
interesting because it looked at young
people and obviously young people
are not yet vaccinating but are
vaccinated but are going out
and mixing so concerns about the fact
that they might be susceptible to
re-infection
before they've been jabbed becky many
thanks indeed
as we head into the weekend let's get a
round up of all this day's sporting
action
jackie is standing by morning jackie
good to see you
good morning neil you too yes got some
really good arsenal goals for you a
brilliant dan
evans win in the tennis and also paint
gates
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
i'm errol mckellar and i've been a
football youth coach
and mentor for over 40 years
we're at the training ground for the
late northern youth team
i've been very privileged to work with
some really really fantastic footballers
the likes of
soul campbell ashley cole ledli king
but when they're passionate and they're
good at what they're doing your job
is not that difficult all you've got to
do is
keep enhancing them working with their
dreams if we don't make them become
footballers we make them become better
people
trust these guys they will get you there
thank you guys i wasn't always a
football coach
i started off as a mechanic that was my
day-to-day job
you know everything was fine until i was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
i found out about prostate cancer purely
by accident when my wife sharon was
complaining about me snoring
went to the doctor i picked up a leaflet
from prostate cancer uk
and the young lady said you don't need
to make an appointment this is a simple
blood test that takes less than 10
minutes i get a phone call
could i come in and have a biopsy done
moving on from that i had a scan
the doctor said mr mckellar your
prostate is covered in cancer
if we don't remove your prostate you
could be dead in six months
and i remember sitting in my car
i just burst into tears because i didn't
know what to do next and my wife came in
the car and she said look in all the
years that i've been with you i've never
seen you quit on anything that you've
ever done
she said this cancer has only knocked
you down it hasn't knocked you out
and i took that as an inspiration
so i had the operation to remove the
prostate i had to have
nearly three months of radiotherapy to
get rid of the rest of the cancer
the first day i went back into my garage
a gentleman came in to
have some work done on his car and i
said when was the last time you had your
prostate checked
and he said what the bleep bleep bleep
is that i've got two my gear box not
working
and i said to him listen i'll give you a
20 discount on the work i'm going to do
on your car
if you go and get your prostate checked
two weeks later he came back
he had a 25 cancer
in his prostate he said to me look don't
worry about the money
more importantly i think you need to
start raising awareness of this issue
right because i wouldn't have gone and
done this check
had you not said it and
he was the first of 48 guys
that walked into my garage no different
to this
that was diagnosed with prostate cancer
one in eight men suffer prostate cancer
committed to getting 100 million people
20
more active by 2025.
[Music]
uh jackie thanks very much i think uh
let's take a look at a couple of the
other stories kicking around this
morning at the united states
first the country has announced
sanctions against russia
following a major cyber attack moscow
has denied the allegation
the russia's foreign intelligence
service was responsible for the
so-called solar winds cyber attack last
year
today i've approved several steps
including expulsion of several
russian officials as a consequence of
their actions
i've also signed an executive order
authorizing new measures
including sanctions to address specific
harmful actions that russia has taken
against u.s interest i was clear with
president putin
that we could have gone further but i
chose not to do so
to be i chose to be proportionate the
united states is not looking to kick off
a cycle of ex
of escalation and conflict with russia
we want a stable predictable
relationship if russia continues to
interfere with our democracy
i'm prepared to take further actions to
respond
still to come on sky news breakfast
we're going to be joined by the royal
commentator jenny bond as the final
preparations take place
for prince philip's funeral
it was a really like slowly but surely
process i started to see my school's
coming back
and at the same time i think i realized
it actually looked down and the the
pandemic was going to last a lot longer
than i originally thought so i thought
we're going to be at home a lot longer
um i'm going to be spending more time on
the row machine could this be an
opportunity could this be a way to make
it work
and rather letting it work against me
actually it worked for me because i
could manage all my family time
around training and so yeah it's kind of
worked that way
well a lot of it's done at nap time so
i'm as soon as they go down for a nap
i'm straight on the road machine and
generally waits if i'm doing weights at
home
the kids join in or i'm reading stories
between sets and it looks
entirely different to the setup that i
had free london and pre-rio
but um i always think if i'm if i'm the
best mom i can be first that allows me
to be the best rower i can be
and i think definitely taking that onto
the water when i do get to go and train
on the water as well i think of it i
just
managed to kind of compartmentalize the
parts of my life well i wake up with the
kids first and i haven't i actually have
a couple of hours with them in the
morning through the early hours and
that's really really nice and then i get
to
to leave the house a little bit later
than i used to so a lot of my training
schedule is just done around them it's
not around them and their schedule
and um i'm really grateful that polly my
my own partner has just been
totally flexible about letting that
happen yeah definitely
definitely i think that mums can be so
supportive of each other and that's just
incredible the first person
or one of the first people that i phoned
when i was thinking about coming back
was
anna watkins she won gold in london and
attempted to come back after having
children
and although she didn't quite make the
olympic team she's the one that you know
has all the advice for me and if i don't
make the team
i want to be the person that someone can
call and you know offer advice to them
and i think that
supporting each other is one of the best
things we can do yeah if the olympics
hadn't been delayed
i would be watching from my sofa there's
no there's no possible way i would have
even
considered making a comeback in that
time scale so it's
yeah it's totally changed everything for
me this year i just wanted to make sure
that this year i came at the end of it
having i don't know having achieved
something having done something that i
never thought possible
i mean i i genuinely had a heart don't
really think about the gold at the
moment because
i'm i'm thinking about selection i'm
thinking about making it there this time
last year i was i was not even a rower
let alone thinking about the olympics so
that's a little bit beyond my thinking
at the moment
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body
can be damaged by air pollution
[Music]
most places will be fine today with
sunny spells once early murky conditions
clear
the best of the sunshine will be across
northern and western areas
it'll be mainly dry too except across
the far northwest of both scotland and
ireland where it'll be windy with some
patchy light rain possible
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will remain at a low level
of 1 to 3 again today thanks to the
mostly fine and settled conditions
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
welcome back labour has criticized the
government's rollout of its kickstart
job scheme claiming it is too slow as
analysis from the party shows that it
may not be
fully rolled out until get this 2043.
joining us now the shadow working
pensions secretary
jonathan reynolds mr reynolds good to
see you this morning um
just explain exactly what your research
has revealed 2043
it does seem like that might be just a
little bit too long for any government
scheme to get rolled out
well the kickstart schemes target is a
quarter of a million
work placements being created and so far
by the end of march
6 000 have been created so if that rate
of rollout continued i'm afraid it would
be 22 years
until the scheme delivers what the
government have asked now
the serious point we're trying to make
on this is that if you look at who has
lost their job over the last year
or 600 000 people who've lost their jobs
since february last year
who are under 35 so 88 of the
unemployment that's been caused in the
pandemic has been
hit on those younger workers
specifically i know because of the
follow scheme which everyone supported
and everybody wanted continued
unemployment has been mitigated overall
but we shouldn't forget there is still a
problem there
these people need support because the
people who are most affected by periods
of unemployment
are of course younger workers who can be
scarred by that for many years to come i
mean we should say of course this is a
government scheme very much in its
infancy no one expects the progress
to slow even further the expectation is
that it will get quicker
but i suppose what what you're in
essence arguing is
we're just not doing enough to support
young people right now well absolutely
and the focus has to be on right now one
of the things that we've asked for
is that time spent on furlough is
considered in terms of the impact on
younger people
as well as the time spent unemployed
because a person could be on furlough
they could be economically inactive with
all of the downsides we know that
creates similar to unemployment
obviously better than being unemployed
but then with a period of unemployment
after that the impact in terms of being
out of the labor market being out of
active work for so long
is very very significant so we think the
government has to do more
and frankly the focus has to be on
delivering it as soon as possible not
about the next financial year not the
end of this year
let's get some action now but but as it
stands i mean the scheme itself
kickstarter i mean you seem quite in
favor of it it's quite a good idea
positive we certainly believe there
should be interventions now we would
actually like
the overall level of ambition to be much
greater than it is at present so we
would like for any
a young person under the age of 24 who's
been out of work over on furlough for
over six months
to be guaranteed a place like this or an
apprenticeship or full-time education
because frankly even if the overall
number of of jobs was hit under
kickstart even if it did actually hit
full capacity
that might not be enough because that's
because of the scale of the impact and
how it has hit younger workers
and we've got to be aware of that so
what we've got at the minute is a scheme
which maybe not
isn't perhaps not ambitious enough but
even that level of ambition is not being
delivered
can we talk about a couple of issues
that seem perpetually to to a rise in
politics
accusations of both cronyism and
corruption and this morning
at the labour party is making some some
pretty significant accusations
about the conduct of the health
secretary well
i think if you look at what we've seen
over the last week i mean we're talking
here about you know in my brief sure
1980s levels of unemployment it feels
like we're back to 1990s levels of
tory sleaze and the crucial issue here
is transparency
and there is not enough of it there
should be it doesn't matter whether it's
a former prime minister like david
cameron
uh telling us he hasn't broken any rules
because he told us the rules don't
cover him as an in-house lobbyist we've
got the civil servants having to write
to other senior civil servants asking if
they're
double jobbing for private companies
they're also in charge of awarding
contracts to you
and now this issue with the health
secretary where a very straightforward
personal connection which would be
and should be declared in the usual way
hasn't been and i think people are sick
of it to be honest
just i just wonder how sick of it you
actually think the people are i mean can
you envisage circumstances in which
you know government contracts should not
be awarded
to companies in which ministers or civil
servants have a financial interest that
would be a start wouldn't it
well i think the crucial thing has got
to be transparency it doesn't matter if
they're doing it just as long as we know
that they're doing well
because that could that could cover
something from a very large contract or
something relatively minor so we have to
be aware of that
in cases where someone stands to
financially gain considerably themselves
from a decision they may be making i
think that's inappropriate i mean i
think that no one should be in a
position where they can
make a decision which will be to their
own personal benefit i think i'll be
completely wrong
so i think you could have transparency
but with some some as you say some rules
about
exactly the extent of that we mentioned
civil servants having you know double
jobbing as you put it i mean
there are plenty of people who would
like civil servants to be doing one job
and one job alone but i suppose the very
same could be said about
you know many mps who seek employment
outside of the palace of westminster
well i think being an mp is a job and
it's a difficult job and it's an
important job and it should be your main
focus i think there there are minor
issues around people who write books or
maybe have a newspaper call them i don't
think that's what the public are worried
about
when i see especially when i was a
shadow treasury minister and you'd be in
those debates in the budget you're in a
finance act
and people get up and all they have to
say is i refer the house to my register
of interest and i would look each one of
those people up usually on the
conservative side i've got to say
you know to see people not just earning
a bit extra but earning six figure sums
on top of that do you think that
do you think mp should have said i don't
think you should have an interest as
large as that
if you're earning you know 200 300 000
pounds on top of being a member of
parliament i think that's
you know dedicating the time that being
a member of parliament requires and
as i said i know there are particular
issues around journalism and
authorship of books and things like
academic journals no one is
perhaps as concerned about that but this
should be your main job but there's no
doubt about that
jonathan reynolds great having the
program thanks for being with us
now final preparations will be taking
place today
ahead of the funeral of the duke of
edinburgh
just 30 people wearing face coverings
will attend the service
due to coronavirus restrictions the
funeral procession
beginning just after two o'clock
tomorrow afternoon
and of course live here on sky news
these are beautiful pictures that we
have taken
in windsor this morning looks like it
might be similar conditions tomorrow and
let's bring in
the royal commentator many of you will
be very very well well aware of our
jenny bond
at joining us on the program this
morning jenny pleasure to have you on
uh this morning and you'll have seen the
details that the palace has released
about the the funeral and and of course
things clearly were going to be very
very different
because of coronavirus but but what do
you make of the way in which
they have orchestrated a a huge event
for the family of course
uh of the prince but of course for the
nation as well
well i think in the end because the
covert restrictions have made it so much
smaller than was planned there would
have been about 800 guests there
in the end you know i think it is the
kind of funeral that the duke
would have wanted and i think it's going
to be that much easier for the queen
because she's not going to have to meet
and greet him in the way you can in kobe
times um 800 people this is going to be
a family funeral and the guest list
makes it clear that is a funeral
about the duke it's not about anyone
else but the duke which is why
three members of his the german side of
his family have been invited
um that the only representative of the
mountbatten family
is penny penny ramsey um penny natural
she is
um the the count of mount batna she is
and she was his great
mate she was his driving carriage
companion and i think
the queen has really made it focused
totally on the love of her life who
she's lost and for whom for the queen it
will be the saddest day clearly of her
life
as you say the count is perhaps not one
of the more
one of the names with with less public
brand recognition
than some of the others are there any
names that that perhaps were not
on the list of course we have uh
representatives of course from uh from
from
the the duke's family in german
connections of course
oh yes that well the german connections
was a great surprise actually
um but but apparently this this was one
of the duke's wishes
um we all talk about the solitary
background he had and it was a very
difficult rootless childhood but he
loved his sisters
um he had these older sisters four of
whom married into the german aristocracy
and so he was separated from them by
geography
he he did love them and they loved him
and it was one of his wishes apparently
at his funeral that german side of his
family should be
represented so that was a surprise and
it must have been a very quick decision
because they've been over here
quarantining uh
since the weekend jenny some are perhaps
making much
out of the fact that princess william
and harry will not be
standing shoulder to shoulder at any
point during the funeral
what do you make of that is that
something that people are right to pick
up on
i think it's sad i think it is a lost
opportunity i i mean
you know that they all know that by not
walking
side by side whatever the significance
of that truly is
they must all know that it was going to
draw speculation
that the rift between them is very very
far from mended
so the my question to them is why not
walk side by side
and again you have to feel sorry for the
queen managing the sensibilities and
sensitivities
of her family not only over whether the
boys should
walk side by side about who should wear
uniform because uh
it seems that the duke of york wanted to
wear an admiral's uniform to which is
not entitled
um and harry would be embarrassed by not
being able to wear a military uniform
she had to think of all these things
when honestly
the poor lady nearly 95 having just been
widowed
should not have to think about these
things in my opinion
jenny bond good to have you on the
program this morning and of course to
tap into your expertise thanks very much
for being with us
time for us to check in and see how the
weather is looking today nas is standing
by with the details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking fine and
settled once again across the vast
majority of the uk and ireland we
continue
with high pressure keeping the weather
fine but
it is actually quite cool for the time
of year and so far this april
average maximum temperatures have been
slightly below
average and nights have been very chilly
as well in fact no exception for this
morning a chilly startup this morning
with a fairly widespread frost some
patches of mist and fog across
eastern areas freezing fog in the
northeast a bit cloudy and breezy and
less cold across the far northwest
otherwise lots of sunshine sunny spells
carrying through into this afternoon
maybe a bit cloudy across central
southern and eastern areas and the north
west of scotland cloudy and breezy
with a little bit of rain later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
naz thanks very much indeed stay we are
coming up in the next
hour here
something subjected to strictly
controlled work programs which could
amount to forced labour
[Music]
so
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to the
safety rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
so
you